OK, so I've got a bunch of clips to play for
you.
We're gonna get them out of the way in the
segment, then move on to an interview.
We'd get a lot of a lot of other things.
But I if I didn't cover this, you'd really
be missing a lot of important sort of narrative
changes that are taking place right now from
the White House and in the context of the
2020 presidential election.
Donald Trump did both a press briefing and
an interview with Fox News host Laura Ingram
last night.
I'm going to start with the interview with
Laura Ingram, which Donald Trump was promoting
all day, multiple times, tweeting things like,
for example, I will be interviewed on Ingram
Angle tonight at 10:00 p.m. on Fox News.
Enjoy.
And there are a lot of really interesting
sort of psychological dynamics going on right
now in terms of Donald Trump taking on these
interviews and winging rallies, as he said
in New Hampshire over the weekend and so on,
because remember that Donald Trump believes
he always is the smartest person in the room
and that no matter what people throw at him,
he's going to come out looking good.
And this is why Donald Trump at least seemed
open to the idea of sitting down with Robert
Mueller back during the Russia investigation
days, something which his lawyers knew would
be a terrible idea, that Donald Trump would
lie, he would perjure himself, it would be
a disaster, and they were able to keep him
from doing it.
And so the context of Trump coming in, thinking
he's going to be super effective went bad
really quickly yesterday in this interview
with Laura Ingram, where she regularly would
try to sort of interrupt and redirect Trump
because she realized that he was going in
a completely whacky direction.
There are probably more than just these instances.
I'm going to play for you and we'll look at
some of these in more detail.
But look at all of these moments where Laura
Ingram just interrupting Trump to try to divert
or redirect what are disastrous paths for
him to be taking, essentially trying to save
Donald Trump from himself.
They say that when you walk through the streets
of Portland, this is years and years of burning.
And it's not the last 90 days.
It's been really.
Oh, no, it's been horrible in the last.
But no, it's people that are in the dark shadows,
people that.
What does that mean?
That sounds like conspiracy theory.
Talk show people that you haven't heard of
the people that are low income housing.
And with that comes a lot of other problems,
including crime may not be nice.
People are criminals.
No, I'm not saying that at all.
But it does.
There is a level of.
In the meantime, he might have been going
for a weapon and, you know, as a whole big
thing there.
But they choke just like in a golf tournament.
They miss a three foot.
And comparing it to golf because of course,
that's what I'm saying.
People people make people choke.
And now I do wonder, you know, we'll never
know.
But does someone go to Laura Ingram and say,
listen, if Trump starts going down this path
or that path, try to interrupt to try to get
in the way, or is she doing that out of her
own desire to help Donald Trump?
We don't know.
Now, let's look at some of the details of
what was discussed.
We talked yesterday about Donald Trump bringing
in this guy, a neuro radiologist, a doctor,
but not someone who has anything that, you
know, any expertize in infectious disease.
Scott Atlus, who is pushing for a herd immunity
approach to dealing with the virus.
I told you yesterday why it would be a disaster.
Here is Donald Trump.
Now, I told you it would happen.
Donald Trump starting to push this idea of
Americans, frankly, in both parties who aren't
comfortable will wish to a certain number.
You know, we use the word herd dread.
Once you get to a certain number, it's going
to go away.
So, you know, it doesn't have to be.
But, yeah, I mean, a lot of people are not
going to want to do a lot of people don't
want to do the mandate.
You know, I never had the flu, but I never
had a shot.
I never had the vaccine.
I come here.
The first thing is, sure, you have to have
a flu shot.
I said, Why?
Because you have to have it.
I say, what's the percentage?
And I wasn't thrilled with the percentage.
You know, it's like 50 percent, 50.
Dr. Foushee said it might not give, quote,
great protection because it's a coronavirus.
Well, I said, look, I've never had it.
Wouldn't it be good?
And then I thought I should have it because
I'll set an example.
So I had it.
So I've had it now three times, but I still
haven't had the flu.
So maybe I'll give credit to the flu vaccine.
I don't know.
So, of course, Donald Trump seems still to
be confused about flu vaccines.
We're going to skip that just because I can't
cover everything.
But I did the math for you on herd immunity
yesterday.
So here here are the numbers for the level
of of contagion for how easily spread corona
virus is.
To get to herd immunity, you need 50 to 83
percent of the population to be immune.
If you pick a number in the middle, it's 67.
It's like two thirds now with a one percent
death rate and 331 people, 331 million people
in the country.
If you do some back of the envelope math,
if two thirds of the country gets.
The virus, that's about 220 million, if one
percent die, it's about two point two million
deaths, meaning we still have two million
deaths to go to get the herd immunity.
If you think the death rate is more like point
seven five, then you're still looking at about
one point five million dead from where we
are today.
So the herd immunity idea is downright dangerous.
And Donald Trump understanding nothing is
pushing it.
OK, let's continue.
Donald Trump suggests, listen, if you don't
count the state of New York in Corona virus
numbers, we're doing way better.
Bad decisions on nursing homes.
He's the number one state in the country by
far.
Four deaths.
I mean, probably the whole world for death.
You take New York out of the equation.
I think we have among the best numbers anyway.
But you take New York with the best numbers
in the world.
Countrywide.
No, Andrew.
So this this is one of those meaningless claims,
right?
If you take out the top five states, our numbers
are way better.
If you don't include nursing homes, we reduce
the death toll by like 40 percent.
If you take out people over age 75, this virus
really hasn't been that much of a disaster.
This is imaginary nonsense.
Does Trump know that it's nonsense?
I don't know.
I actually don't know.
Here is Donald Trump, sort of weirdly second
guessing police incidents.
And we saw a little bit of a preview of this
earlier in the compilation of Laura Ingram
trying to help Trump here.
Trump likens police incidents to putting in
golf where sometimes people choke, you know,
a joke.
They choke shooting the guy.
They shoot the guy in the back.
Many times.
I mean, couldn't you have done something different?
Couldn't you wrestle?
You know, I mean, in the meantime, he might
have been going for a weapon and, you know,
as a whole big thing there, but they choke
just like in a golf tournament.
They miss a three foot and comparing it to
golf because, of course, that's what I mean.
I'm saying people should be called make people
choke.
And an outrageous analogy, of course.
And Laura Ingram realizing it and trying to
do instant damage control for Donald Trump.
But it just kept getting worse and worse.
This next clip is a really interesting insight.
Into the psyche, really, of Donald Trump.
Take a look at this.
Feel like me.
They feel like every time I put law and order
up on social media, it gets such an incredibly
positive response.
The people of this country will not stand
for it.
So Trump recognizes whenever he posts a tweet.
Law and order in all caps.
A lot of people like it.
It gets a good response.
Notice that he's saying I get a good response,
not when I do anything, but when I post Law
and order.
This is a microcosm of the entire presidency.
During the Chris Wallace interview in July.
This is, by the way, I tweeted about this.
This is relevant to bring up, Trump said during
the Chris Wallace interview in July.
Within two weeks, we will have a signed and
delivered new health care law.
It's going to replace Obamacare.
It's going to be done in two weeks.
That was in July.
That came and went during August.
Trump was asked about it.
He said, we're going to do it at the end of
the month.
And Trump is starts saying Trump's doing new
health care.
Trump's doing health care.
As you probably know, it's now September,
August.
Thirty first came and went.
And Trump didn't do it.
Trump either recognizes or simply doesn't
care that he doesn't actually need to do stuff.
He gets a lot of the political benefit just
from saying he's going to do it.
And that's exactly what he's saying here when
he says, I post law and order and people absolutely
love it.
Then Trump went into wild conspiracies about
the city of Portland, for example, which he
claims has been burning for years.
They say that when you walk through the streets
of Portland, this is years and years of burning.
And it's not the last 90 days.
It's been really oh, know, it's been horrible
in the last.
But no, it's been going on for many.
It's been going on for many, many years.
It's like you're in I won't name the city,
but it's a city, some place in the world.
It's not so good.
Okay.
It's a terrible story.
The governor said Portland has been burning
from years.
Like, what is that?
What does that even mean?
Firefighters just let things burn for years
in point.
None of this makes sense.
The facts don't matter.
But this is the narrative Trump has chosen.
Trump has staked out this place in order to
get himself from now until election.
The election he's made the calculation it
may work.
It may not.
That chaos is good for him, even though the
chaos is happening under his watch.
It may work and it may not.
And I got some interesting pushback yesterday
from people writing and saying, David, here's
what your take is wrong.
The chaos won't work for Donald Trump and
we'll discuss that.
But the point is, Trump thinks it will help
him.
He was asked, would he put Dr. Foushee in
charge again if he were to do it all over
again?
You wanted to do it all again.
I know that's a car.
Kind of a hard question, but do it all again.
Would you put Foushee front and center every
day in charge of the Corona Virus Task Force?
I get along with a very well I disagree with
a lot of what he said.
He said keep it open for China.
That was a big mistake.
And he admits it.
I just I get along with him.
But every once in a while, he'll come up with
one that I say, where did that come from?
I inherited him.
He was here.
He was a part of this huge piece of machine.
I didn't put anybody in charge.
He was here.
He was.
He's been here for 40 years.
Eighty four.
Nineteen.
OK.
He's been here for many, many years.
But and I know you inherit a lot of people.
It's part of the machinery.
He inherited Foushee.
He says sort of like a stepchild that came
with your partner.
Came with the relationship.
I inherited him.
So no real answer there.
And then again, restating this wild claim
that he's done more for black people than
anyone except maybe Abraham Lincoln, but maybe
even more than Abraham Lincoln.
What do you think for them?
I've done more.
And I said in the speech, some people would
say, you shouldn't say it is too aggressive.
I said, what's agressor?
I've done more than any president in the history
of our country except for maybe Abe.
And I said, maybe, maybe Abraham Lincoln.
The reason I say maybe is I'll explain that
to you later.
Okay.
The funny that every time Trump says this,
nobody says, what about LBJ?
Maybe Jonathan Swan from Accio said, what
about LBJ?
Although I don't I don't remember.
And if he said it, I don't know that Trump
even heard it.
I'm going from memory.
But aside from the Lincoln conversation, nobody
mentions LBJ in this discussion.
It I can't even pretend that this is serious.
But Trump continues to say it.
And then here is where it gets really just
dystopian in explaining that someone is secretly
controlling Joe Biden right now.
Donald Trump suggests that there was some
kind of thwarted terror plot against the Republican
convention involving thugs on a plane.
But he won't go into detail.
He's not controlling anything.
Who do you think drawing Biden strings?
Is it former Obama people that you've never
heard of?
People that are in the dark shed.
Those people that.
What does that mean?
That sounds like conspiracy theory, talk show
people that you haven't heard of.
There are people that are on the streets and
people that are controlling the streets.
We had somebody get on a plane from a certain
city this weekend.
And in the plane, it was almost completely
loaded with with thugs wearing these dark
uniforms, black uniforms, with gear and this
and that.
There they were on a plane.
Where's the water?
I'll tell you sometime.
But it's under investigation right now.
But they came from a certain city.
And this person was coming to the Republican
National Convention and there were like seven
people on the plane like this person.
And then a lot of people were on the plane
to do big damage.
So is that completely made up?
Probably not.
It's probably not completely made up.
It's probably a combination of something that
happened which Trump first misunderstood and
then exaggerated that as apologize for hitting
my microphone there.
It's probably something Trump misheard and
is exaggerating now for some unclear, an unknown
benefit.
So this is the president talking about, you
know, a plane loaded with thugs in black uniforms.
I wonder if their uniforms were the only things
that were black about those so-called thugs.
That's certainly a question.
And then he says he says this person.
But was it a person or was it a group?
Even Laura Ingram unable to save Donald Trump.
And remember, Donald Trump's psyche allows
him no consideration other than I'm going
to crush this interview.
I'm so smart.
I'm so good at being interviewed that everybody
is going to come away super impressed.
Unfortunately, I think some of his followers
do come away from an interview like this.
Super impressed.
The reality is absolutely horrifying, almost
as horrifying as Donald Trump's press briefing,
which I want
to talk about next.